here now our two parents virginia
appearance azra nomani and ian pryor
welcome to you both and congratulations
it's really um we've been saying it all
week it is the election of the mama and
papa bears and definitely the
organization of the parents in in
loudoun county and throughout the state
has made a big difference in this
election
um i i look at it and it just seems so
simple to me osra i mean teach my kids
reading and writing and math um don't
show them pornography don't turn them
into little marks as activists
why couldn't the democrats get this
message and what was wrong with these
school boards why were they so obstinate
in this
you know since june 2020 we have been
standing up at our school board meetings
and we have been pleading with them to
listen to us but unfortunately the
school boards have been hijacked by
these activists and these educrats that
are part of a multi-million dollar
industry pushing this ideology of ideas
like this little book wolf baby by
um you know authors
and
there is a very real thing called
critical race theory in education
it's spilling into our classrooms and we
the parents are saying exactly what mr
yonkin was saying we want schools to
teach kids how to think not what to
think it's a
pat next part of that and we are not
white supremacists because of it i am
not a white supremacist i'm a muslim
woman born in india and an immigrant but
i love my baby and every mama bear and
papa bear loves their child and nobody
can put hands on their cup yeah
absolutely they they really um mess with
the wrong people ian um i i try to look
at what are the lessons from what
because i think america is looking at
what you guys have done there and are
thinking what can we do i know i've
tried to go before schools to make
change and one of the first lessons i
learned was don't do it alone because
they'll make you think you're crazy um
and i think what was so effective is
that you guys organized and you guys
were a group and so they couldn't just
dismiss you guys as all being crazy um
what other lessons do you have for
parents those mama and papa bears across
the country as they want to get critical
race theory and this pornographic
material and all this gender ideology
out of their schools
yeah you know it's a great question and
i've been saying for a while there's
really three components to kind of what
we did uh you need to investigate you
need to communicate and you need to
activate you know investigating means
sending freedom of information act
requests
getting the stuff that's going and
taking pictures in the libraries finding
out what books are there and then you
need to communicate you need to
communicate it to other parents um so
everyone knows what's going on you can
share information and then communicate
it to the media because the media is has
been on this and they have been um
highlighting this and then finally
activate you know we we obviously built
an organization from scratch we call it
the back deck pack pack um and you know
we wanted to focus on school board races
but we were able to put together a team
of volunteers that were just fantastic i
mean they spent six months collecting
signatures to remove school board
members we're done with that process and
it's all because of their hard work and
then the more you work the more you do
all this it has a snowball effect and
you bring more
yeah you both have been an inspiration
everybody in virginia who worked with
you has been an inspiration the nation
was watching and hopefully they'll be
activated um ian azra thank you so much
for joining me tonight hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else